everybody get down on the floor
do you need some quick cash for all-out
options what have you robbed the bank
think about it you need money banks have
a lot of money and besides today the
government guarantees people's deposits
anyways
no one's gonna get hurt it's a
victimless crime so let's theoretically
learn how to rob a bank number one do
the unexpected study data on what most
bank robbers do on their heist and
figure out a way to do the exact
opposite to confuse law enforcement
number two want some help
if you're gonna bring people on you
better trust them with your life number
three pick the right bank whatever bank
you choose you wanna make sure they have
multiple escape routes so that when the
police arrive they won't know which
direction you took off in number four
get a getaway car that no one would
expect like a sleeper car or prius
number five banks and cops have gotten
more sophisticated against thieves so
have backup plans in place
number six rob them doing at night is
safer but takes a lot more skill in
planning doing it during the day is
easier but riskier number seven almost
done before you can use that money you
have to make sure it looks legitimate by
laundering that money once you launder
your score you're good to go
this is a joke for entertainment
purposes only would you not condemn
illegal acts click that plus sign right
over here for more micro business video
essays just like this one